water is the essential ingredient to
life as we know it everywhere we look
water is where life is so that's why the
mantra for Mars exploration has been the
spire follow the water we know some of
the places where water happens to be
because that's critical you don't want
to send humans where there is no water
on Mars
you know just below a layer of dry
regolith basically dried dirt there's a
nice table with ice you can really for
the water actually it really you get
those eyes
and you put ice is not any different
than Antarctica there's solid water on
Mars in the form of ice that if all of
it were to melt at once the entire
planet would be a thousand feet deep in
water we already have the technology to
just about perfectly recycle and if we
need to they're going to take that water
clean it up get all the sewage out of it
and treat it with chemicals and other
things and you'll be drinking it it's a
cleaner and safer than your tap water
when it's done it's not just because
we're gonna melt it and brush our teeth
with it but also because water is made
up of hydrogen and oxygen and those are
the two components of rocket fuel and so
you break apart the hydrogen and the
oxygen and now you've got this fuel
source and that can help sustain you and
keep you in this place